hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i am filming from
my iphone
because this is a setup video and i can
really only show you the setup
if i'm not using the setup for context
i'm currently in australia visiting
family because my sister just had a baby
i'm an aunt for the first time
but before i left la where i live i was
like okay
e3 is coming up that's a whole bunch of
streams that i'm going to want to do
i want to make sure that i can still
make youtube content i want to make sure
that i can still
video edit and i definitely have this
conundrum in front of me of like okay
i'm going home for longer than i would
usually go home for because there's also
a two-week quarantine period in a hotel
for you to be able to come to australia
right now so there was this big wall of
obstacles that i wasn't sure how to
approach
as someone who generally just does all
of that
from a beefy pc so i had to do some
brainstorming to make sure that i could
travel
and still play games still stream
still video edit video editing probably
being one of the hardest hurdles there
from anywhere i'm also jumping between
three houses i go from my mom's house to
my dad's house sometimes to my sister's
place
but obviously also the hotel room so
this needed a lot of mobility
and initially i just really wasn't sure
how i was going to manage
but this is what it looks like right now
i am at my mom's place this is my mom's
office with this
giant calculator she has up there
but this right here is
my remote streaming setup this
is it i'm currently uploading a video it
does take a little bit longer in
australia than it would
otherwise but first things first very
easy microphone solution that i find
very easy to move
is the elgato wave 3. the reason that i
like this microphone so much especially
for traveling is because it's really
modular
meaning that it's very easy for me to
take this whole thing apart to remove
the base to remove the stand and to
remove the top
uh to make it very easy to put into a
backpack it's also great sound quality
and also
acts as a sound mixer the elgato wave 3
comes with a software called
the wavelink that allows you to if
you're streaming streamers will know
what i'm talking about when i talk about
this
it allows you to have different channels
for different things so i can have
discord and one channel
my game audio and another channel which
is generally just desktop sounds
and then my microphone in a third
channel so if i want to edit any streams
down
they're not all on the same track now go
to away 3 has been awesome
this is a little bit more of a refined
version than what i have at home i
usually have a mic
arm i also have a filter on it but
for on the go this is great so easy to
be with so easy to pack down it fits
into a really small pocket in my bag
it's wonderful
next up here i have already made a video
about this but this is the razer
keo pro now the reason that this webcam
i think is so helpful for me um
obviously if you want to have something
that's even more stripped back you could
use the built-in
webcam on a laptop but the reason that i
really like the keo pro
is because it's a really good camera for
low light um dramatically
uh improved compared to the previous
webcam that i was using
um and i don't have a lighting setup
that was a choice that i made
was i wasn't gonna bring a light with me
you could bring a portable light you
could
um get you know a small ring light that
you would attach on a tripod if you're
traveling that's not that hard to do
but i made the decision that i wasn't
going to do that and was instead just
going to use
the razer keyo pro generally i'm using
natural lighting so things work out okay
but a lot of my e3 streams
were at like 3 am because
on australian time that's just the way
watching e3 press conferences really
goes
okay so that's the webcam next up is my
portable
monitor setup this beautiful thing right
here
is actually very interesting let me show
you guys
how this thing works okay so this
is the mobile pixel us um
and it is a screen that attaches to the
back of my razor it connects through
usb-c it's in the side of the screen and
then connects
at the back of the laptop and can be
used in a bunch of
like if i want to show you guys what i'm
looking at like a presentation style
it pivots backwards so i could do that i
could flip it directly to the back i
could pop it out to the side
pretty much tons of options with this
thing so
it is actually um a screen that that
slides back into this case
and magnetizes to the back of your
laptop
there are four magnets that i have that
are stuck to the back of the laptop
the screen you stick on here
and then you slide this out now the
reason that this has been particularly
um
important for me is not only does it
make video editing very easy because i
have my premiere pro on this main screen
and all my files
on this side screen it's also really the
only reason that i can
successfully twitch stream without
needing another backup monitor
i have my game running on here
obs running on here in a smaller screen
and then the chat
running on here as well so my main
screen is how i play the video
game the side screen is how i see my
recordings
and the chat and all my stream setup
it's awesome for that these two together
are just um
perfect so of course last but not least
is my razer blade 15.
this thing can run cyberpunk uh disco
elysium
cell attack conspiracy um i've also
played a bunch of gmod i played dungeons
and dragons on it
and for the most part capable of running
those games at the same time
as running obs i am running a six core
intel core i7
nvidia geforce rtx 3070 laptop
gpu fhd 144hp hertz
512 gigs of storage 16 gigabytes of ram
an advanced heat pipe razer chroma
gigabit internet
and it's only 19.9 millimeters
it definitely gets weightier when you
have the the mobile pixel screen on the
back of it
but for the most part is a very
lightweight
easy to carry tidy laptop portability
um compared to the functionality is
incredible premiere pro
on my pc at home just keeps on crashing
on me
or it'll freeze for a while i have not
had any of those problems
on the razor blade whatsoever i am very
happy with it and for how simple this
whole setup is
i fitted the whole thing into a backpack
i break down the microphone
i fold up the laptop and it all fits in
one backpack that's carry-on on a plate
everything has worked so smoothly and i
guess there's also
kind of an extra upside to this whole
setup
is that you can really do it
anywhere and i mean anywhere
it's lovely
and that is it for me today everyone it
feels very weird to have shot a video
mostly on my phone for the first time in
ages
with the intention of showing you guys
this wonderful setup that i have here
but that really is everything if anyone
has any more questions please do let me
know
because i am so so so glad to have found
this setup
and have not had any problems in the
last two months
really at all thank you all for watching
i will see you guys next time